[Musique]
mais
plus de mille personnes ont été mises à
l'abri et les sapeurs pompiers ont
procédé à plus de 130 sauvetage sont des
personnes qui étaient en difficulté soit
chez elle soit à l'extérieur dont un peu
plus de 21 litres oeil âge réalisé par
plus de trois hélicoptères
[Musique]
voilà venir ici
on
[Musique]
en maintenant on va mesurer les dégâts
parce que les dégâts ya des dégâts
apparents et puis il ya d'autres dégâts
qui sont moins apparent avec le le
retrait de leurs traits de l'eau je
pense qu'on aura besoin de deux sets de
ceux de ce dispositif catastrophe
naturelle pour vite pour vite vite
rendre service aux gens qui en ont
besoin et opter l'itv tu es aussi
[Musique]